LAURA LING: Graduation
time is approaching,
and Kelly Acevedo, a
senior at Manual Arts High
School in South Los Angeles,
will be the first person
in her family to go to college.
But the pathway hasn't
been without challenges.
Kelly, did you see a lot
of violence growing up?
KELLY ACEVEDO: Outside of my
house, it was a lot of gangs.
And my sister was always
involved with them.
I saw so many graphic things
that she went through.
For example, the
day when she got
raped, I was like
seven or eight,
so I didn't know how to react.
It kind of made me
lose my childhood.
LAURA LING: Did you ever
think about joining a gang?
KELLY ACEVEDO: No.
It made me more focused.
I was always the
nerd of the family.
LAURA LING: To
protect Kelly's sister
from the influence of gangs
the family moved to Mexico.
But Kelly always longed
to return to Los Angeles
where she was born.
KELLY ACEVEDO: I really
wanted to get an education,
and be someone in life.
So I asked my parents if I
could come back to Los Angeles.
And at first they disagreed
with it because I was too young;
I was 14.
But as time came by my
parents agreed with it.
LAURA LING: Were you nervous?
KELLY ACEVEDO: Yeah,
I remember my dad
leaving me at the airport.
And my mom stayed home.
And I remember her crying.
It was kind of scary.
That was like my first
time being on a plane.
And I didn't know who to
ask, like where to go.
LAURA LING: It's a hard
decision to make at only 14.
KELLY ACEVEDO: Yeah.
LAURA LING: Kelly
moved back to the US,
and stayed with relatives.
But it was a
difficult transition,
and she faced further
obstacles at her new home.
KELLY ACEVEDO: It's just hard
because at first they didn't
even provide me anything.
I was sleeping on the floor.
And it was just like a blanket
in the corner of the floor.
It was hard to do
my homework just
with like a little flashlight.
If I turned on the light,
they would yell at me.
LAURA LING: What kept you
going through that time
because it could have been
easy to give up, and turn off
that flashlight, and just not
continue with your studies?
KELLY ACEVEDO: At first I was
just angry and upset that I
had to go through that.
I thought at that moment,
you're going to be in college,
and it's going to
be better for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: How
hard have you had
to work to get where you are?
KELLY ACEVEDO: It was
difficult because I only
knew fifth grade English,
so I felt really behind.
I had to practice
my writing, and make
sure my grammar was right.
I would try to read as
many books as I can.
LAURA LING: And then
finally you caught up.
You're in classes where all the
super smart kids are in, right?
And now you have
one of the highest
GPAs in your entire school?
KELLY ACEVEDO: Yeah,
I'm number two.
So hopefully I'm going to be
the Salutatorian of my class.
LAURA LING: That's awesome.
Kelly is deciding whether to
attend UC Berkeley or Wesleyan
in the fall.
But before then she has
some celebrating to do.
You do a lot of
extracurricular activities.
You're in ROTC, the Leadership
Council, the prom committee.
Are you looking
forward to the prom?
KELLY ACEVEDO: Yeah, I'm
really looking forward to prom,
especially because
we're organizing it.
LAURA LING: She was also chosen
to be part of a TLC channel
event called, "Say Yes to
the Prom," which gives prom
dresses and makeovers to
deserving young women.
KELLY ACEVEDO: I
think that's wonderful
because a lot of people from
my community can't afford that.
But we also look forward
to it because it's prom.
It's something special that
happens in your senior year.
LAURA LING: What part of
prom are you looking forward
to the most?
KELLY ACEVEDO: I'm
looking forward
to I guess being a
child again because
throughout my whole life,
I've had to act like an adult,
and carry so much
responsibilities,
like look out for myself.
[? If ?] I lookout to eat, or
have clothing, or I don't know,
school supplies, and
stress about money.
So it's amazing that I can be
able to participate in prom,
and just enjoy the time
I have with my friends.
And not worry about any
responsibilities I have.
LAURA LING: A few weeks later
Kelly reached her biggest goal
yet.
She was selected to be in
The Gates Millennium Scholar
Program, one of the most
prestigious scholarships
in the country, where
she will receive
full tuition for her
undergraduate, graduate,
and doctorate studies.
I mean you have been
through so much Kelly.
I mean more than I think
a lot of young people
can ever imagine.
What do you think has kept you
going, and kept you motivated?
KELLY ACEVEDO: What's
kept me motivated
is to always think
about the future.
And also what motivates me is
my parents and my grandfather.
He was always there
for me, and always told
me to be good in school.
And I just want
to make him proud.
And show him that I made
it, once I become someone.
LAURA LING: Please check
out this next video.
SPEAKER: It's
almost like a dorm.
But the people aren't
young, they're old.
SPEAKER 2: Our project is
called, "A Home That Fits."
This is one solution
for youth homeless,
a problem in Helsinki.
LAURA LING: Thanks for watching,
and be sure to subscribe
to "Seeker Stories."
[MUSIC PLAYING]